this graph y equals x cubed okay this
pot is multiplied it's not moving around
or anything like that spec where it is
okay
but what is not well defined in this
line here y equals MX minus four okay so
what we know about it is that it has to
pass through the y-axis at minus four so
it has to go through that point but it's
gradient we don't know so we don't know
what angle it slices through the y-axis
at okay now the question is what values
of n are possible appropriate allowable
if this line is tangent to this curve
okay that's the question this line
tangent to this curve now the reason why
I was continuing is because a very
well-known questions you guys if I make
it a two instead of a three
okay because all you have to do is find
the point of intersection and use the
discriminant okay it's a tangent so this
should be one solution so the
discriminant should be zero right
because that case you want the solution
underneath you take the square root
square root of zero so you got plus or
minus zero one answer okay
but when you look at this side right
you've got execute and we don't do your
discriminates for cubic functions okay
because there we engrossed so how do you
solve it if you can't use the
description does any suggestions how
would you go about even starting a
question like this
what's your first instinct
so I'm gonna draw here right so I've
started a sketch okay what else can I do
with it
all I've got is the cubic function I
test every gradient hmm
so that's called out we've talked that
proof by contradiction and prove my
induction that kind of hurt but believe
it on a hazard name it's proof by
exhaustion
unfortunately no it seriously is called
proof by exhaustion because you're
exhausting all of the possible options
the problem with that is that how many
possible options are there there okay
now let me ask you this what do you
think is six tell you about how many
answers there will be if you had to
guess like not knowing what it is but
how many answers do you think there
would be to any other thoughts why any
other thoughts you could have like an
inequality okay if it was you know this
he was s squared okay you'd probably had
two solutions right you're expecting to
tend to go off the answer is one but the
question is how can you know that what
someone hands up if you said one who
said one hands off straight come on
stand up for what years which okay
James why why did you say one what why
why was your instinct that way
no way I want to play finish my mission
yep yep okay let's let's go after that
sir one of the things that we've noticed
is attention to the curb right it's only
gonna intersect once and he say it has
to intersect on the right side okay
which is correct why kind of intersect
on the left
why not I'm trying to get at you to
think of this right and not just because
you can't just apply a four-wheeler to
this question that's one of the reasons
why it's a good one
why can't it go through why can't it
intercept with the curve on the left
hand side well you could just think
about it visually right if you have to
pass through minus four
okay what kind of line could you draw
that would go through the left-hand side
and it would be a tangent right like if
you draw a line like this that's clearly
not a tangent looks more like a normal
if you draw it draw it further up this
way things are getting worse right if
you draw down this way it looks a bit
better right the gradients it's time to
approach each other but he'll never be
actually equal right so it's either
going to hit straight through or yeah
it's just not gonna be very helpful okay
so it does hit over the right it's fine
okay that's the lion all right now the
question is what wine is it how would
you go about working yeah what kind of
lie minutes I told you for this is kind
of a mishmash of year 11 and 12 that's
right
so what kind of information do you know
all kind of concepts that you know about
that help you to deal with tangents and
gradients and all that kind of thing so
okay so me to tell you slave will give
us a point of intersection right but
that doesn't tell us about gradient yeah
because you can have a line that goes
through the curve and it hits at one
place but it doesn't share the same
grade so it's not a tangent what else do
we have
yeah yeah we could differentiate right
what should we differentiate all right
so instead of saying dy/dx because
there's two y's I'm gonna say the
derivative of x cubed is 3x squared how
does that help does it help
okay good so what this is telling us is
you can pick a point and that'll give
you that will generate the gradient
which is why we call it the gradient
function okay so how can we use it to
help us solve the question what should
okay so you want me to find a point of
intersection right in other words you're
gonna find where where this point is
okay so how do I go about doing that
what do I do what I do
sub 3x squared into what into error okay
so just like this so let three x squared
equal to n is that what you think okay
so therefore that line the straight line
will have an equation sorry y equals 3x
cubed minus four what does that mean
something's gone wrong okay and here's
why okay even though it seems like a
fairly sensible thing to say this right
this is a constant at least it looks
pretty constant to me it's a number
right this is not a constant it's a
function okay so that's why things start
to break down if you let a variable
thing equal constant thing okay so
that's a bad idea what else could I do
okay I can solve somewhat I see what
should i solve someone's here - yeah I
have lots of different equations what
should I put together 3x squared 3x
square which is gradient what do I want
to solve with
hmm what options do we have
I could make it equal to this for this
right so I could say MX minus 4 for
instance okay if I solve that what will
I get at the end what we result will I
have